in a flat in Moscow Veronica Essen is
giving away her belongings I've done a
lot of photographs of my stuff and I've
put them on the Instagram page she's had
enough of Putin's Russia and can't get
out fast enough whichever way she can
I'm gonna I don't know Ram run somewhere
between the borders or I I'm gonna
figure out some somehow how to how to go
away I feel that
there won't be any happiness in Russian
Federation for a long time
and
this economical crisis will just be much
bigger and bigger and bigger and
people are gonna lose a lot of money
at the offices of the few Airlines still
flying to Russia there are long queues
but leaving isn't as simple as hopping
on a plane
so a lot of people here so they are
trying to get out of Russia the problem
for us is they're not prepared to be
interviewed about it because they're
worried that authorities could watch
that and then turn them back at the
border some of them have got friends who
have already got out of Russia but they
say they were closely questioned at the
airport and had to prove that they are
going to come back
Russia faces a massive corporate Global
boycott under severe Western sanctions
in aviation Boeing has suspended part
supplies for Russian Airlines Airbus has
followed suit car makers Volvo Ford
Mitsubishi BMW Honda and jaguar are
suspending car exports to the country
and in the world of entertainment Disney
Sony and Warner Brothers won't release
new films in Russia Apple won't be
selling new iPhones there and is
suspending Apple pay
young Russians are suddenly cut off from
the Western services and products
they've come to take for granted maybe I
can with without Disney it's okay but if
without production of Apple I think it
would be it would be hard for me you
need your iPhone
at Apple pay and Apple pay yes and today
Apple pay didn't work
stores are shutting the Moscow Stock
Exchange suspended trading for another
day and exodus is underway as Russia's
economy begins to implode and Putin's
repressive rule only tightens its grip
Dominic wagorn Sky News Moscow